bien alors je vais vous faire ça vous
étonnera pas jean claude brialy
je veux faire une interview cire pompes
il n'a pas bougé comme d'une vingtaine
lui cire pompes j'aurais pu l'appeler
l'interview drucker mais je l'appelle
pas être désagréable avec ni chef tu
nous regardes des jouets 600 fois la
puce à l'oreille de 150 fois mon père
avait raison entre 1
vous êtes quand même aussi un immense
acteur de théâtre non je pense que je
suis un immense quand le serpent
ah oui d'accord avec un bruit sur moi je
crois que je suis bien mon métier que
j'aime bien
alors on continue interview sur pompe
patron d'un théâtre des bouffes
parisiens mais pas d'un restaurant
laurie vous réussissez tout ce que vous
touche à l'âme vous verrez que je
voudrais tout chez elle venir directeur
que cet été vous allez faire deux
festivals le festival d'anjou et de
ramatuelle et de ramatuelle
il ya un festival sacha guitry à dax
troisième festival
non là je ne gagne pas ça bien sûr je
viens jouer la pièce et ouais avec mon
père les réseaux prétexte qu'à dax qui a
grand hôtel grand hôtel où aller sachez
qu'ils m'ont amené ces femmes lie à
s'ennuyer tellement elysées elle
s'ennuie tellement que pta l'on peut
faire l'amour toute la journée c'est
bien c'est joli
dites moi on peut dire votre âge ah oui
67 ans des bâches ont bien pour votre
âge
oui et au lit je suis à jeune homme un
jeu de crise on se crée c'est que je
crois que j'aime les autres et que je
dors bien voilà je crois que quand on
aime les autres
vous savez il ya une très belle phrase
d'arletty elle lisait la meilleure crème
de beauté c'est la bonne conscience
et quand on sent dans le soir en ayant
fait ce qu'on devait faire de ce travail
qu'on a été sincère et qu'on a essayé de
donner la main alors l'autre on dort
bien nommé vous entendez l'aï meilleures
crèmes de beauté c'est la bonne
conscience elle a pas besoin de crème de
beauté les ravissantes non mais attends
mais j'ai eu quand même le droit de dire
que vous allez ravissante là mais je
pense à
voilà merci volume vous la chanter cela
aussi non